le conseil général de la réunion vous
présente lien social le conseil général
aux côtés des réunionnais notre île a la
chance d'être ensoleillé
une grande partie de l'année et c'est
bien connu le soleil donne le sourire et
la joie de vivre c'est quelque chose de
très facile à constater
il suffit de regarder le sourire des
jeunes enfants réunionnais cette joie de
vivre est accompagné d'une solidarité
d'une volonté naturel d'aider et de
soutenir sa famille son ami son voisin
celui qui en a le plus besoin
cette solidarité et cette chaleur
humaine propre aux réunionnais arrivent
à traverser l'océan indien pour profiter
aux plus démunis dans la capitale
française
grâce à l'antenne du conseil général des
étudiants réunionnais et les restos du
coeur samoussas achards de légumes
karrikia marron tard tu manques coco il
s'agit bien sûr d'un menu créole que
prépare cette brigade de jeunes
réunionnais leur implication à la tâche
nous laisse entendre qu'il s'agit de
futurs cuisiniers professionnels
eh bien non ces jeunes réunionnais font
des études supérieures
ici à paris c'est avec le sourire et
dans la bonne humeur que cette équipe de
cuisiniers amateurs prépare un repas
complet malgré un emploi du temps chargé
ces jeunes trouvent le temps et
l'énergie de préparer un bon repas
créole aux plus démunis de la capitale
c'est dans cette péniche la péniche du
coeur opération montée avec les restos
du coeur que des sdf pour la majorité
viennent trouver un bon repeint un peu
de chaleur et aussi beaucoup de
réconfort
jennyfer et bénévoles sur la péniche du
coeur cette réunionnaise de 25 ans en
doctorat de chimie
m aider les autres pour elle c'est tout
naturel d'apporter du soutien à ceux qui
sont dans le besoin
que ce soit à la réunion ou ailleurs
enfin pdg restos du coeur qui a été
créée par coluche et
donc c'est le conseil général qui
finance un repas tous les quinze jours
pour les héberger de la péniche donc
c'est et vergers sont des sdf qui sont
pour un laps de temps sur la péniche
c'est à dire qu'ils sont soit son
domicile fixe soit sans papiers dont
poids divers profils quoi en gros c'est
ça
et donc tous les quinze jours le conseil
général finance un repas dont c'est une
équipe de des étudiants qui viennent
cuisiner un repas et une entrée un plat
et un dessert
et puis partager avec eux par la suite
le repas et puis faire des activités
jeux aux jo car tous se regarder la télé
est discutée par interagir entre
bénévoles et hébergé moi je suis arrivé
à paris l'année dernière dont on se
souviendra longtemps que cher paris et
au début d'année j'ai reçu un mail du
conseil général parce qu auparavant
j'avais une bourse avec eux je vous ai
envoyé un mail comme quoi que si j'avais
des actions que c'était bénévoles pour
cuisiner passer un bon moment convivial
sur une péniche avec des hébergés donc
moi j'ai répondu présentes et c'est que
la classe de ce soir a commencé et après
les héberger ils attendent le repas
réunionnais tous les coeurs jo ils sont
tellement contents qu'ils aiment ça sur
ma nature j'aime aider les autres j'aime
faire plaisir aux gens et j'aime
m'investir dans quelque chose il est le
fait d'être la péniche
je sais que
les évangiles sont contents quand ils me
voient et enfin ça n'est un petit peu de
baume au coeur dans le train dans leur
coeur à quoi ils sont peints ils sont
contents ils sont ils sont joyeux et
puis ça lui avait alors permis d'avoir
aussi en contact un contact mode que les
gens malheureux quoi parce que non on
n'est pas là pour les juger en fait on
est là juste pour qu'ils passent un bon
moment et leur faim et qui se sentent
rien donc personne ne juge personne et
on est là juste en train pour passer un
bon moment de convivialité tous ensemble
faut le faire avec coeur comme jennifer
beaucoup d'étudiants réunionnais éprouve
le besoin d'aider les gens
c'est donc tout naturellement que le
conseil général soutient financièrement
des actions de solidarité et mobilisent
les bonnes volontés
deux jeunes réunionnais le département
est fier de participer à des actions
comme celle de la péniche du coeur c'est
un moyen d'entretenir partout dans le
monde
cette solidarité qui fait partie des
particularités des réunionnais on sait
que les réunionnais sont formidables et
nos étudiants qui partent en métropole
faire leurs études sont aussi formidable
mais ils ont également la générosité du
coeur puisque ça fait aujourd'hui
plusieurs années qu'ils participent à
cette belle opération des restos du
coeur avec la péniche et ils font goûter
le rougail saucisses créole le bon
massalé a assez à ces gens qui sont tout
contents de pouvoir avoir un repas
réunionnais et mérite véritablement à
une médaille particulière une mention
particulière de la part du conseil
général
bravo à ces étudiants pour cette belle
opération
grâce à ces jeunes étudiants volontaires
dévoués et le soutien du conseil général
la réunion donne une belle image d'elle
celle de son vrai visage en ait trop
paul et dans le reste du monde
de cette manière elles démontrent qu'il
y a des valeurs humaines à préserver à
transmettre à partager des valeurs
fortes qui bat dans le coeur de tous les
réunionnais le conseil général de la
réunion vous a présenté lien social le
conseil général aux côtés des
réunionnais